so soft and crumbly pops are beautiful
shiny curl up on the couch and
enjoy hey tasty fam keanu here and i am
at my kitchen studio jaconi and i'm
going to teach you today
how to make scones they are incredibly
versatile
i'm going to be making my favorite
version but also walk you through all
the different types of varieties
you can make at home and the best part
is you can enjoy them hot and fresh but
also
pop them in the freezer so you can have
fresh cones anytime
so the ingredients i'll be using are all
purpose flour
whole milk unsalted butter eggs
white sugar baking powder raisins
vanilla extract
and chai masala all right it is time
to bake time to bake
first things first i have three large
eggs
love a dark yolk and i have some milk
three quarters cup whole milk when
making scones
fat f 80 is what makes everything so
delicious yes you can use
skim but it'll just be a little less
buttery
a little less adding a teeny bit of
vanilla extract you can totally do this
without vanilla
but with the spices i'm going to add
it's going to add a bit of warmth to it
beat this really well so there's no
streaks of egg white
you want it to be very homogenous
mixture now on to
the dry i have five and a half cups of
all-purpose flour i like adding a bit of
sweetness
but not as sweet as a cake so i have
about a half a cup
to two thirds a cup of sugar is usually
good
to make sure it's sweet ish very
very important baking powder and a whole
lot of it
three tablespoons of baking powder
this is one way to assure your scones
will not be
stoned don't be shy on the baking powder
it's going to help you
make them light and fluffy is a little
bit crumbly but you want that it's kind
of part of the scone experience
my palette could use a little something
you sip your tea or coffee a little salt
happens
in here so i'm just going to go for one
teaspoon of kosher salt
if you're using table salt use less
because it is
saltier if you over mix your scones it's
not going to be
that crumbly flaky texture it's going to
be
this is kind of the opportunity to
flavor it however you like
i love chai just to make sure of spices
that you may already have in your
kitchen you can also
buy it and it just adds in that aroma
cardamom cinnamon ginger
cloves and a little bit of black pepper
so flour is nice
and mixed together and this is where i'm
going to incorporate the butter
this is just under two sticks so one and
three-quarter six of butter
cut into little cubes it's very very
important that your butter
is cold cold butter will give you flaky
scones that is the mantra
cold butter flaky scone these are your
tools
it's going to go pension and the first
part is you want to lightly
just toss it around so all the butter
is coated in the flour and once it's
nice and coated it's when you go in with
the little pinch claws
and start smushing the butter in between
the flour
at any point if you feel like the butter
is starting to melt in your hands
pop it in the freezer let everything get
nice and cold again
and then back to the pension even
distribution of the butter
is key integral incredibly crucial
can you tell this is important by now
it's just still very much resemble flour
so this is looking good nice and crumbly
flour so
time to move on to the next step
to my dry mix i'm going to add in that
milk egg and vanilla liquid
as well as some
raisins raisins work well chopped
apricots
dates as well as some types of fresh
fruits so you can do a blueberry scone
dice up some apples some pears those all
work really great
so if you have some lemons on your
counter oranges you can
zest them and incorporate that in there
for a little bit of brightness and
flavor
really your imagination is the limit
when it comes to how you flavor a scone
once those mixed together it's not going
to resemble a
homogenous so like a cookie dough it's
still really crumbly
the time has come i'm going to turn it
out onto a very
lightly floured clean work surface
and just dump it all out and it's just
one
jumbled mess the only thing to do is to
squish it together so bring in the sides
the top and i want to shape it into
a square and i'm just going to be using
my
bend scraper or any just straight
plastic thing to help
bring it all in and help kind of
minimize my hand contact
so pat it down until it is one inch
thick
all around it's time to cut and really
the choice is yours at this point if you
want it square if you want a triangle
you want it round
do whatever you like it will all cook
the same and cook beautifully
so i'm using a round cookie cutter
around two and a half inches in diameter
and wiggle it out baking sheet
very simple lined with parchment paper
and just
pop the scone right on top and then just
continue cutting until there's no more
dough left
and then gather up all the scraps and
keep shaping until
the dough is gone all the scones are cut
out and i divide it into two different
trees
one tray going right into the freezer
and then the other tray for enjoying
right now
so for the batch i'm going to bake now
i'm just going to
brush it with an egg wash i'm using just
an egg yolk
with a pinch of salt just mix it
together i have a
regular pastry brush if you don't want
to use another egg
or don't have enough eggs to spare you
can use
some milk and heavy cream it's not going
to be as shiny
but it's better than putting in naked do
not put your scones in naked
be very very delicate once this egg wash
bakes it's going to have that beautiful
like shiny brown just like you see in
professional bakeries
because you too are your own baker i
just do the tops
you can do the sides if you want to just
a really light layer
does the job every step of making scones
is so soothing the crumbling
the brushing if you don't have a pastry
brush i have done this
with a paper towel and just little blots
and dabs
you're going to lose a little bit of
your egg but hey gets the job done
it's all you need you've seen them look
good all this labor
for them to look mediocre good they're
so cute
so these are egg wash and ready to bake
in the oven 350 degrees
until they are golden brown and
beautiful so about 20
minutes
while my scones are in the oven baking i
want to show you how you can freeze
the rest this is a two-step process
part one you want to freeze them
individually
not touching at all no touch everything
needs its personal space to get nice and
frozen
and then once all of the scones have
chilled out literally to their
frozen solid then you can put them all
into a single ziploc bag
label and it can store for three months
this is one because you absolutely want
to eat while it is piping hot
you know they're done when the bottoms
just have like a little tannins to it
and the tops are
beautiful shiny i'm going to eat this
with a little bit of
jam oh boy so soft and crumbly
so it doesn't even cut quite perfectly
but what you want
you can spread it on top like toast or
just keep it by you
and just spread it on bite per bite
holy moly you cannot eat a scone cute
i swear i want anyone to try it because
if you made these right they're a little
bit crumbly
so it should just like fall apart in
your mouth but also melt a little bit
have yourself a cup of tea some coffee
curl up on the couch and
enjoy so that is how you make scrubs
feel free to customize it make it your
own
and if you do make this recipe please
show me
tag me on instagram i love to see what
you're baking until next time
farewell oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you